especially when those breezes hit you
we've got temperatures well below normal
again this morning look how beautiful
the skies though nice sunshine northerly
breezes always bring us some nice nice
good air quality and that's what we've
got out there this morning we also still
have a couple of neighborhoods in the
40s nellis and mountain's edge opposite
corners of the valley everybody else in
the 50s but still some northerly breezes
at times especially up in north las
vegas making it feel extra cool 40 at
red rock and 28 up at kyle canyon again
our morning temperatures should be in
the mid 60s perump is in the 40s this
morning boulder city in the low 50s low
50s up in mesquite let's talk about
western drought conditions because of
course that is what's fueling these
wildfires like the one in laguna last
night yesterday and still working on
that fire today extreme to exceptional
drought so extreme in the dark areas of
orange to red here but where you see
like that really deep deep kind of
reddish brown that's exceptional drought
and we've got that here and south
central nevada but over in southern
california the drought conditions have
worsened over the last month and of
course southern california down to
just one watering day a week as they
head into their hot summer months for us
we've got a lot of heat coming and the
winds have switched around now yesterday
those were coastal winds coming in off
the ocean but today they're also going
to have more of those northeasterly
santa ana type winds no wind advisories
that have been issued for southern
california in the area of the fire in
laguna but to areas north they'll have
some wind advisories yesterday we had a
little snow in the mountains a little
bit and we had some afternoon clouds but
today we should be cloud-free with lots
of sunshine again there are some wind
advisories for socal those are north of
l.a not down around laguna where those
two nearly two dozen homes destroyed in
that wildfire that just just got out of
control so quickly with the dry
conditions just dry vez vegetation and
that's what happened and that that wind
just pushed that fire uphill and those
burn those homes burn so quickly 55
degrees up in our local mountains with
partly cloudy skies for a high and a
little breezier up in the mountains than
down here in the las vegas valley 78 for
a high yesterday we were 69 so we're
going to make up some ground pretty
quickly and try to get some normal
temperatures back tomorrow 90 degrees so
a little above the norm and then we jump
into hotter temps this weekend our first
triple digits of the year for several
days no heat advisories for us even
though we're well above we will be well
above normal but if you're sensitive to
the heat you may just want to pace
yourself don't overdo it outdoors